the eight news now i-team uncovering
what led up to a smoke shop robbery
turned stabbing and then the
consequences for the teens who did it
it's a story many viewers have responded
to and only our camera has been in court
as the teenagers responsible for the
crime face a judge the i-team's vanessa
murphy has more today from juvenile
court
while the teen who was stabbed remains
in the hospital the other two teens
learned their fate here in juvenile
court the judge sending one of them to
spring mountain youth camp the other to
a juvenile correctional facility we also
learned more about both of their
histories and how their parents say they
repeatedly tried to get them help his
story alone
would be an amazing movie
of what happens to a child how it
happened and how it went through the
whole system and he ended up here these
are the adoptive parents of this teen
seen on video at a las vegas smoke shop
robbery on august 3rd
the store owner stabbing one of the
three teens the other two running i know
what i did was wrong and i regret every
bit of it the teen's attorney saying he
was exposed to drugs while in his
mother's womb the court previously gave
you an opportunity judge sonny bailey
acknowledging how he was abused by his
biological parents beaten so badly at
six years old he was unrecognizable his
adoptive parents saying they've tried to
get him the services he needs to cope
with the trauma without success
unfortunately the systems in the state
don't
they're not good for that from
self-medication to previous run-ins with
the law because of a bomb threat and a
weapon judge bailey pointing to the
chances the teen has already had and
sending him to a juvenile correctional
facility the teen seen holding the door
in the video also offering an apology i
apologize
not only to the star on me
but to everybody that was affected
by my actions judge bailey sending him
to spring mountain youth camp his father
pointing to the loss of two family
members to murder and also saying he
tried to get his son help i'm reaching
out to the courts
asking
not for mercy leniency or any of that
but asking to get the proper help i need
to save my son from becoming a statistic
or a full-fledged member of
the penal system
now the long-term injuries for the teen
who is stabbed are not yet clear his
lawyer says he is expected to need to go
to a rehab center after he's released
from the hospital
reporting from juvenile court vanessa
murphy 8 news now